thank you very much for coming tonight's
different it's not really jokey poo
i'm doing thing about criminal stories a
lot of people always email me god put
together something about your criminal
stories
so i figured i'd do it and a lot of them
so you're going to hear some [__]
don't judge me all right [__]
you know before you watch law and order
they have like a [__] thing you know
the chris criminals you're about to see
whatever the hell are true
the names have been changed whatever
it's the same deal here i'm gonna keep
some of the names and
but these [__] stories are true you
know
you know in november of 87
i was out of my mind you know and i
kidnapped somebody
yeah i kidnapped somebody
i told you you're gonna hear some crazy
[__] here
but see you most of america thinks
kidnapping is i take you home and i
write a note to your mother
and i want money and then they negotiate
back and forth the cocksucker's only
worth 25 cents and
that's not kidnapping that's on a grand
scale kidnapping is when you move a
person from one dwelling to another
without them wanting to do it so if i
put a gun in your stomach
and move you from the bedroom to the
kitchen even if i don't shoot you
it's kidnapping then there's levels like
anything else
one two three i'm not a [__] law
major i don't even know this was what it
was
i'm living in boulder colorado and i'm
selling cars i'm going to university of
colorado
and i'm doing great i'm snorting blow
you know i'm smoking dope
i'm working out and i'm making money i
don't even know what the [__] happened
also next you know i get caught up
with this guy was gonna sell some other
guy coke and i was gonna rob that guy
you follow this is how it started this
is why what a tangle web we weave when
we tangle to deceive whatever the [__]
it is
because this guy comes to me and he goes
my roommate has
two kilos of coke i'm gonna rob it from
him and i'm going to sell it at
wholesale
and i'm going to split because he had a
warrant out for his arrest
so he was going to move to arizona and
start new money at this time this is
boulder colorado
this is boulder 30 years ago where it
was nice white people with sandals on
that's it
i stuck out like a sore [__] thumb
you follow me
but i made it work for me you know what
i'm saying i worked on the accent the
whole thing
and uh i was gonna jump this guy i was
like listen this guy's gonna rob
somebody why don't i [__] rob him
take the coke cellar in new york and
come back [__] him
so i knew i called some of my buddies in
jersey in new york and they couldn't fly
real quick like i had to do this in two
days
so i went with this biker dude that i
knew from the car wash you know he had a
pit bull he had the [__] car the
tattoos i figured you know
he's ready he was bald the steroids he
was telling me about machine guns and
[__] i go this guy will do it so i
i try to talk to him meantime
i just ran it by him he comes back to me
and he goes listen bro we need that
heist
he goes i'm dating the stripper i'm in
love
he goes she's living with me but she
won't [__] me
because she's married and she's catholic
so so while she's married to this other
guy
she won't [__] me i go wait a second she
dances
nude they give you bottles to drink
there she gives you lap dancers with a
[__] out no shorts
this ain't hooters this is straight up
monkey
in your face and she's worried about cat
catholicism at this point in the [__]
game
but he bought into it and i'm like oh
this guy's gonna be a [__] beauty you
know what i'm saying
so the day comes i go pick up this vela
guy and i
you know i gotta lie to him like we're
gonna go to this house to sell your coke
to this [__]
dude he's got the cash he shows me the
coke he shows me a draw full of cash and
this other
container coke and it was like an ounce
and a [__] thing and
it was like 1800 worth of cash and we uh
i make the kid go to this guy tidwell's
house and
his mother owned the house but there was
no furniture in there and we go inside
and the [__] kid rips out a [__]
gun like
and he's trying to rob the both of us
now
i'm like you [__] so i'm like
what are you doing and he couldn't rob
me because he didn't know where the coke
was see i knew where the [__] blow
was see that was my
ace in the [__] hole that's how i
roll
so i said you ain't robbing me [__]
we're doing this together you're trying
to drop a double cross me
and i used to live in colorado and
colorado at the time you could just go
into a [__] 7-eleven and buy a gun
you didn't need no you know all you
needed was a driver's license if that
like if the guy wasn't on the phone he'd
just write you up and give you the
[__] gun
oh yeah come again and here i am with a
[__] nine millimeter you know what
i'm saying i mean
this was you know 20 years ago 20
something years ago so
i had this gun in the trunk of the car
you know
and i'll never forget well he was going
to try to rob me and stuff i'd go all
right you go over to the guy's house
and find the coke i'll stay with this
[__] idiot tied up
right and he comes back and he goes
there was nothing there
i could you go on the draw and i knew it
was 1800 it was
there was like 200 cash so i'm like this
guy's trying to rob me so i tell him i
go listen
you tried to rob me [__] you this is
your mother's house you're stuck with
this [__] in your house
i ain't taking them with me and on the
walk out i'm like you know what
i'm gonna shoot these two [__]
because listen i was about 28 i was a
little frustrated you know
and i always wanted to shoot somebody
just [__] just like like in the leg or
something just to shoot him ah
just you know i'd seen it done and it
looked [__] cool you [__] stand
there bam bam you know
so i'm like i'm gonna go shoot these
[__] and you know what don't
even laugh because it's true
i was going out to the [__] car it
was broad daylight it was a suburbia
neighborhood they would have never heard
nothing
they would have found them a week later
with flies on them and i would have been
long [__] gone and i would have
fulfilled my fantasy i wanted to shoot
two [__]
i get out to the thing i go to the trunk
of the car it was under the tire and i
took the gun out
and i had the clip in there and i put
the thing in my back and i'm just gonna
go in there and blow their [__] heads
off
and as i walked through the front door
something i said you know what
i'll know you know i'll [__] know i
shot these [__]
so i said you know what i'm not even
gonna do nothing i'm just gonna go home
and i didn't even really go home i went
back to
the kid's house and he had those
ceilings with the thing that you push up
and they have this invisible ceiling i
just ripped it the [__] down
and a [__] two kilos came down
wrapped in colombian newspaper
and i took them you think i'm [__]
kidding you they were wrapped in
colombian newspaper i knew the weather
in bogota that day
they're following me i picked those
[__] up i'm like it's 90
degrees in cartagena
ain't this a [__] and i went outside
and i did old school i put in a
newspaper thing you ever see those
newspaper [__] things you put a
quarter in and open it up
you know how much [__] money has been
moved through those when you're trying
to get the l.a times
because you give a [__] about the lakers
one if you look at those things there's
a ledge on the bottom
where they used to put the papers go
under there there's leaves and [__]
every once in a while somebody would
leave an ounce of coke there and i knew
this [__] like just
this is the old way listen i'm gonna get
a paper put an ounce under the bottom
you put a quarter in put the money under
there and then but sometimes a cop
pushes by he's paranoid he leaves the
money in there
what a great place to either i hide the
kilo or coke and then i run home
i call my buddy he comes over picks up
the two kilos takes it to aspen
and i wait at home i take an eight ball
to go you know me cause you
gotta work that jaw you know what i'm
saying you gotta work that jaw
so i take the [__] eight ball home i
do it i i'm up till four juggernaut by
myself looking out the window
and finally at like eight i wake up to
[__] banging on the door you know
boom boom boom boom boom boom
this is kid brett he was a detailer at
the subaru place where i was a salesman
he knocks on the window i opened up
what's up he goes bro the dealership is
surrounded with cops
surrounded they're looking for you
they're on their [__] way
so i go i get dressed i clean the house
i throw the scale out
and as i'm walking out of my [__]
house they're pulling up the block
and i cross the street i go to a
supermarket and i'm watching them they
pull in front of my house
like eight of them they come out with
their guns drawn they're knocking on the
door
nobody's home i'm at the thing watching
these dumb [__]
and i uh i watched him leave but they
left two guys on an unmarked car
i go into king supers and i called my
girlfriend at the time i go listen
that thing would happen yesterday
backfired you got to come down and get
me
because the car my car was in the
driveway so she comes down
and i as i'm going this is how [__]
crazy i was i go holy [__] i left my
weed over there
and at the time i was getting weed
mailed to me from new york city this
chocolate thai weed
and i'm like [__] it i walked two mo two
blocks
around the back of the thing with the
two cops in front of my house
i jumped the fence went in and got the
weed and jumped back out
and i went to the [__] thing and met
my girlfriend that's how [__] crazy i
was i was crossing the street for
[__] weed
okay she lived on lee hill road up in
the mountains so i went up to the
mountains and chilled out and i called
around and the cops were everywhere
looking for me
so i said [__] i'll sit up here and
watch movies i got steven seagal above
the law
and [__] mel gibson uh whatever the
one he did with the black guy that's
when it came out like that week
so uh not amistad the other one he did
right
it's so uh
so uh i never forgot i had to go get
those videos and i was across from an
albertans
and by this time the cops had been
looking for me my name was in the paper
that that what happened was
tidwell the genius that he was
takes the idiot villa that we kidnap and
puts him in the trunk of a car
and drives him to the bus station in
downtown denver to put him on a bus
but on the way to the station guess what
he did he forgot to put the headlights
on
he gets pulled over the cop asks for
license registration all you hear is
[__] banging out of the back trunk
they open up the trunk and here's
[__] the guy handcuffed and he's like
joe diaz did it
you know so now that's what [__] can you
imagine the luck so i was doomed from
the beginning
so i remember calling the uh the police
station going yeah this is joey diaz and
they put me on hold
they were trying to trace the call you
know what i'm saying i'm ahead of this
[__] [__]
i've been watching tv for years
[__]
so i hang up i call back you gotta be on
hold hang up
finally i call me like where are you and
i go i was in front of a k-mart i'm at
albertsons
and they go sit right still so i hang up
the phone i'll never forget within
minutes
[__] cop cars just pulling up and
they're running into albertson's heat
meanwhile i'm a k-mart watching this oh
[__] thing
i get my car i'm gonna have to turn
myself the [__] in you know
i turned myself in the neck and it was
funny because that's the night uh
don johnson was getting married to tina
marie or whatever on miami vice
it was a friday night i had to turn
myself in and i remember telling my
girlfriend go
listen drive me down and i'll be i'll be
out by the wedding because i wanted to
see don johnson get married on miami
vice
i'll never forget going like don't worry
about it i'll be out for the [__]
wedding i'll tell them something you
know what i'm saying
like i'll make up some [__] story you
know and i go in there and i
oh joey diaz they go i come through this
door and when i go in there's 19
[__] cops with their guns drawing
like get on the floor i'm in your office
you know
they pick me up they got a sheet of
paper you're charged with kidnapping one
kidnapping two aggravated robbery
accessory to a felony
and crime of violence i'm like what
[__] kidnapping what are you talking
about this was no kidnapping
i didn't [__] call his uncle or
nothing what are you talking about
and austin they went into the history
lesson of kidnapping and george
washington
and you know and i'm sitting there going
what the [__] and my bail is
50 000 i'm not even worried about that
i'm worried about the wedding
you're following me i'm like you
[__] ruined my wedding with don
johnson tonight
they put me in a cell it takes me a
month to bail out i bail out
you know i try to get my life together
i'm moving with a guy to move away from
what i was doing and the guy's the
biggest
coke dealer in [__] boulder the guy
i'm living with he's from jersey
he's like yeah i drive a cab [__]
so it's funny because i kept pushing the
sentencing date
because i knew that the victim would
disappear he was this crazy
you know i wasn't going to kill him at
this point he was just this crazy the
other guy that the biker he was in jail
i got out because i knew people in town
plus it was a high [__] bail and i
had to pay an attorney
and he came out afterward they let him
out by mistake
so but the victim he was kind of crazy
he was always with drugs so i thought
he'd disappear so i kept paying the
attorney
to keep me the [__] out of out of the
trial and then finally one day they
called me
your trial is august 15th what do you
want to do and and we kept working them
and this attorney was [__] great he
was jewish
thank [__] god because if you're
going to go in there for your life you
got to go in there with
two or three heavy-duty jews with the
yarmulkes on you know what i'm saying
with sandals with a rock in their hand
those are the jews
they don't [__] around they'll throw a
rock at that [__] judge [__]
we'll turn this into [__] new anyway
so they call me on friday and they go
listen man you've been turned down for
uh community corrections you got to go
in and talk your [__] head off
and prove to the court that you've
changed and you so they made a deal i
was going to do zero to six years it was
up to the judge
so what do i get off the phone with him
i called the dealer i got an eight ball
i got some thinking to do you know what
i'm saying
i got some thinking and some drinking i
do [__] like 22 eight balls
monday i wake up you know to go to court
and i'm like [__] it i'm gonna beat this
the cocaine was talking you know here i
kidnapped somebody with a machine gun
and something had happened like this a
couple weeks earlier like some kid got
robbed and he jumped off his balcony he
broke
both legs they were trying to charge me
with that there was a couple things
going on some other
cuban kid was going to university of
colorado and a pell grant and he was
going to miami on the weekends and
bringing back coke and they found this
car
blood splattered so they were trying to
put that on i mean it was just [__]
amazing like i was getting blamed for
everything
and i'm like [__] you [__] this
attorney really got it down so he got it
down to zero to six
and it's so funny how i'm very
rambunctious and obnoxious
i get the court with my [__] armani
suit on monday morning right
i'm a bad [__] i've been up for
four days straight
i'm on water and vodka [__] red bull
they weren't even red bull wasn't even
in the [__] process people were still
snorting coke with three hands
there was no reason for [__] red bull
and i walked into court and they had the
docket i was like number four and my
friends flew out from jersey
and they had like 10 ounces of blow a
hooker
and i'm like dawg don't worry about
nothing i'll be out in 15 minutes i
actually went in there thinking later
i remember they called jose diaz and
everybody's looking around who's jose
diaz i'm like me joey [__] it
i woke up and the judge says you know
you know what you did that
i do and he goes the probation report
came back you know you [__]
uh you know they said that you wouldn't
res
you wouldn't never get in trouble again
but you weren't copying to it that was
my problem i wasn't respect
i wasn't accepting responsibility here i
was 28 years old living my life with no
responsibility it was always somebody
else who did it
it was his fault it wasn't me you know
in the back of my mind i didn't do
anything wrong i tried to take drugs off
the street
you follow me i was like a superhero
that's why
i was like insulted that they arrested
me like what
i mean i robbed drug dealers for years
not one ever called the cops that's
that's the lock about drop
[__] robbing a drug dealer the cops
say csi ain't coming
the guy with the red hair with the
sunglasses you know he ain't coming
ain't nobody coming
you rob a drug dealer get settled on a
basketball court
or [__] it they don't give a [__] that's
why i was like
what your honor i [__] robbed the
drug dealer will you stop it
will you see what the [__] i did now he
calls me up and i'm up man he's like you
did this you did that
is there anything you want to say and he
just put his glasses down now you see
how i'm talking to you [__]
tonight
i'm a gangster you should have seen me a
[__] came out
of me like i could feel it like my [__]
came out and hair and my dick
disappeared and i was like
your honor and my voice went away
[Laughter]
[Music]
and he's like what happened tough guy
well enough he's like boom four years
department of
i'm like what the [__] i look at my
attention i'm like [__] say something
you jewish [__]
i'm just [__] standing there
scratching your yarmulker say something
[__]
and he's like what do you want me to say
i say tell them i gotta go to school on
monday to let me out these guys bro
they brought an ounce of coke and two
hookers what are you [__] kidding me
i'm gonna go to jail i ain't got time
tell em wednesday thursday i'll show up
with [__] a dress on with lipstick i
don't give a [__]
but i gotta go home and finish this blow
i mean i was really hooked you know
and the judge is like boom [__] no
jew shake his hand it's done
[Laughter]
he shook my hand i remember turning
around to go on a hug like my [__]
wife a girlfriend at the time and my
friends
i had that little tear in my eye like
the indian remember when they threw
littering
i was blown i thought i was going deaf
like are you [__] serious
is it four years what are you fi i tried
to take drugs off the street and finally
they came and got me
they put me in my [__] cell like to
get processed and i sat there and here's
the funny thing i have a nice suit on
brand new
i'm sitting in the [__] cell
and i get like an itch you know you get
an itch on your tit and i get like a
little itch
and you have a pocket over here and i
put my hand in the [__] pocket
and there's a lump in a thing and i pull
it out and it's a [__]
the last temptation of joey diaz
it was a solid little coke rock solid
and they had cameras in the salad i'm
like oh [__]
if i do this i'm gonna have to jerk off
and these [__] cameras
so i crushed it with my fingers and i
[__] put like something
and i snorted it and i [__] passed
out
because i had all this stress on me you
know like when you're going to jail
finally it was over that's what they say
a guilty man sleeps like a [__] baby
you know a [__] guy that's innocent
doesn't sleep it's true i [__] went
in there
even with the whole coke rock i did it
in one shot not like little lines
there's no time for that
you're not bumping but you know you're
not bumping by the toilet right
remember that time in high school nah
there's none of that [__]
you got to do it fast i'm sweating and
all that lost and i just [__] passed
out
and i woke up and it was like three
hours had passed and i was still in this
[__] cell
i'm saying to myself how the [__] did i
get into this [__]